[Musique]
je m'appelle ça rêve lobé et g11
cette année je suis particulièrement
fier de lui pour une deuxième fois testé
en cd parler en public est pour moi une
véritable passion outre les arts de la
scène je suis passionné de dessin et je
fais partie de l'équipe de basketball de
l'école
depuis trois ans je n'ai pas peur de
relever des défis et je m'implique
beaucoup dans mon milieu scolaire
trouver un sujet pour le thème abordé
n'a pas été chose facile mais je suis
restée positive tout au long de mes
recherches
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui je viens vous
parler de la pensée positive
la clé du succès pour une 10e heureuse
j'espère qu'après avoir été cette
présentation vous ne verrez plus vos
apps talent du maroc en novembre dernier
j'ai eu la chance de recevoir un objet
tout cas c'est un certificat remis à
chaque mois par les services de garde
un élève cas s'était montré de belles
qualités du cac bref cela m'a grandement
inspiré pour mon sujet pour cette
présentation
je ne sais pas si vous devez comprendre
le lien qu'il ya mon immeuble du cac et
tout est possible est-ce qu'il y en a
parmi pour qu'ils comprennent rien
faisant un zoom sur l'image peut-être
que cela pourrait vous aider
comme ça et maintenant vous voyez bien
les mots postés en effet après avoir
reçu mon humble du cac je suis
questionné sur l'impact avait l'effet
d'être positif dad
bref mes recherches m'ont amené à
comprendre que le fait d'être positif
était la clé du succès dans notre monde
je vais vous le prouver
tout d'abord il faut savoir que la
pensée positive est un véritable mode de
vie qui nous vient de nos voisins du sud
les américains mais c'est quoi la pensée
postés et bien c'est tout simplement de
décider de penser autrement lorsqu'on
lit sur ce sujet
plusieurs personnes croient que
premièrement la pensée positive permet
de surmonter des épreuves et donald a
dit huang est deuxième à elle permet de
croire en nos rêves de l'époque sous un
autre angle pour réaliser de grandes
choses par exemple
ouvrez une
entrepris et troisième lorsqu'on porte
de manière positive
on répare le bien autour de nous vous
n'avez qu'à penser à une journée où tout
irait bien
vous avez alors un sourire contagieux et
tout au long de cette journée plusieurs
personnes autour de vous sont heureuses
maintenant je vais me présenter un bon
exemple de penser poster bien sur
plusieurs personnes sont postées mais
celle ci m'a grandement inspiré
connaissent yvonnick boutique peut-être
pensez-vous que ce qui le caractérise le
plus c'est son physique particulier mais
détrompez-vous ce qui les caractérise
vraiment ce qu'il ait posté mais vous
allez me dire comment il peut être
positive sans bras ni jambes et bien
c'est ce que j'essaie de pas comprendre
en paix il a utilisé son handicap
positivement pour combattre
l'intimidation et à montrer aux jeunes
dans les écoles car malgré son physique
ne puis plein merveilleux si on y croit
bref avec sa nature postée il fait le
bien autour de lui d'ailleurs sa vie
nous pensons réelle influence sur les
événements les personnes qui se sont
attardés à la pensée posté en sont venus
à cette conclusion
on attire ce que l'on s'aime et on ne
met cette loi la loi de l'attraction
alors qu'ils ne voudraient pas avant une
vie remplie de bonheur d'amour et de
joie
ainsi si j'ai bien compris le fondement
de cette théorie ma vie sera sans doute
heureux car j'ai décidé de donner aux
autres dans mon quotidien c'est pourquoi
j'ai fait partie de la brigade du
sourire dans mon école ce côté ça a été
les airs priest où seul mais pour cela
nous avons besoin de renforts c'est
pourquoi nous avons installé la boîte
associés et c'est dans ces 6 kills et
déposeront tous leurs petits problèmes
mais vous avez vous pensé à ce que vous
ferez pour un montant nettement meilleur
et bien je vous donne un petit indice la
pensée positive c'est la clé du succès
merci et bonne fête soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]